la principal conclusión es el enfoque
diplomático quieren por supuesto
discutir posibles soluciones con rusia
le han pedido a rusia y es algo que
también va a reiterar blinken en su
reunión con sergei lávrov que rusia tome
medidas para de escalar la situación de
lo contrario si rusia hace lo que se
pueda describir como una agresión los
aliados de eeuu y en particular también
alemania pero otros aliados han
asegurado que habrá consecuencias para
rusia por supuesto lo que se estuvo
discutiendo hoy aquí en berlín entre los
principales países que se reunieron en
eeuu francia alemania y reino unido- es
qué tipo de consecuencias podría haber
si en efecto rusia hace lo que se
considere una agresión bueno y después
de estas declaraciones que se espera
puntualmente de la reunión entre blinken
y lávrov mañana en ginebra
blinken dijo hoy precisamente aquí en
berlín que no espera que mañana la
situación se solucione del todo son
pasos que se van a dar hacia una posible
solución el principal objetivo del
secretario de estado será presentar la
postura de eeuu a lo que por supuesto
hizo hoy también aquí en la capital
alemana y presentar también la posición
de los otros aliados de eeuu
precisamente ese enfoque en la
diplomacia algo particularmente
importante para alemania alemania ha
reiterado que quiere tener un enfoque
diplomático muy claro por ejemplo
reactivando lo que se llama el formato
de normandía junto a francia para
negociar con ucrania y con rusia es algo
que también se va a discutir mañana en
ginebra pero falta ver qué tanta
disponibilidad y que tanto interés
también hay de parte de rusia así que
por un lado está todo el tema
diplomático por el otro lado también
está la posibilidad de sanciones o de
consecuencias si el tema se agrava en la
frontera con ucrania